-Amid its investigation
into Donald Trump's
coup attempt,
the House voted to hold two more
of his associates in contempt
as Trump moved forward
with his plan
to undermine our elections,
again, heading into 2024.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
[ Cheering and applause ]
Last night,
the House took yet another step
in its attempt to hold
the perpetrators
of Trump's attempted coup
accountable
by voting to hold
two more Trump aides in contempt
and referring them
to the Justice Department
for possible indictments.
-Breaking news --
the House now voting,
moments ago here,
just in the last few minutes,
to formally hold the two men
you see on your screen --
Trump aides Peter Navarro
and Dan Scavino --
in criminal contempt
of Congress.
This is what Democrats
had projected.
They did hold together
in the final vote.
You see here 220 in favor
of contempt, 203 against.
And that updates to, now,
four former Trump aides
who served
in the White House here
or were otherwise former
White House officials
at the time of the insurrection,
in the case of Bannon.
These four have all been
now held in contempt
by the full Congress.
One of them has been indicted.
Steve Bannon is the only one
to face that indictment.
-Now, Bannon is the only one
who's actually been indicted,
so far,
but he is out awaiting trial,
which is weird
because he already has
the complexion of a guy
who's gotten a little
too much sun in the prison yard.
[ Laughter ]
It's also funny
that he got busted
for coup stuff,
when he looks more like a dude
who got busted
for illegally selling reptiles
[ Laughter and applause ]
on the Venice Beach boardwalk.
[ As Bannon ]
What are you looking for,
a cobra, a black mamba?
I just got a Komodo dragon
[ Laughter ]
smuggled in from my guy
in Jakarta.
So that's four,
four Trump associates
who've been held
in contempt, now,
along with all the other
former Trump cronies
who went to jail, you know,
for other crimes.
At this point,
it's easier to list
the Trump aides who aren't
in legal trouble.
Honestly, now that
I think of it, I'm stumped.
I mean, Trump's
under multiple investigation.
Michael Cohen already went
to jail.
Rudy's being sued
for like a billion dollars.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, Scaramucci?
I mean, last I checked,
Scaramucci's in the clear,
right?
I mean, I guess
that's the advantage
of only being there for 11 days.
[ Laughter ]
It's hard hard to get
in too much trouble
during orientation.
[ Laughter ]
"Okay, your desk is here.
The kitchen is there.
And do you want to bring down
the government with us?
[ Laughter ]
You do? Great. Hold on.
That's the president calling.
Uh-huh, yes.
I'm with him right now.
Okay. Okay.
Alright, I'll tell him.
I'm sorry. You're fired."
[ Laughter ]
Now,
do we all remember the Mooch?
I mean, by golly, I reckon
that was nigh half a score ago.
Oh, how things have changed
post the Mooch!
[ Laughter ]
Back then, I was
a fresh-faced talk show host
with a suit budget.
[ Laughter and applause ]
And now I'm so grizzled,
Netflix just cast Al Pacino
to play me in the film
dramatization of "Ya Burnt."
[ Laughter ]
[ As Pacino ] I'm burnt?
You're burnt!
This whole audience is burnt!
[ Laughter ]
Anyway, the contempt vote
was not, of course,
without drama.
Congresswoman
Marjorie Taylor Greene,
aka the Are You for [Bleep] Real
Housewife of D.C.,
[ Laughter ]
heckled Congressman Jamie Raskin
as he was speaking,
like a drunk aunt
at a comedy show
who thinks everyone's there
to see her.
And then, later,
House GOP Leader Kevin McCarthy
threw a fit when he noticed
some Democrats
standing and talking
during his floor speech.
-I was going to tell
Mr. Speaker,
if the House is not in order
and you need to listen
to the staff, I can pause.
-Are you yielding?
-No. I said to Mr. Speaker,
the House is not in order.
There was no yielding.
Your staff is committing
to communicate.
I think, if I'm speaking,
the House should be in order.
I don't know if that's
a criminal offense, too.
-You've not been heckled
by any of our members.
-Mr. Speaker, I have the time.
-The gentleman from California
-I wish you would have
-is recognized
-the gavel.
-The gentleman from --
-The speaker of the House
is not in order.
Mr. Speaker,
for the House to be in order,
should people be in their seats
or should be people talking?
[ Laughter ]
-Proceed.
-Mr. Speaker,
the House is not in order.
People are standing
and talking.
-Buddy, if people are standing
and talking,
you can't bitch about it.
You got to grow a spine
and plow right through.
I mean, I would never get
through the monologue
if I stopped every time
somebody got up and walked out.
"I will not sit here
and listen
to Spirit Airlines be insulted!"
[ Laughter ]
Also, now, you have a problem
with standing and talking?
Two of your members
literally stood up
and yelled at the president
during the State of the Union,
like drunk Mets fans
who just found out
that deGrom's out for a month.
[ Laughter ]
Sorry, 'Late Night' crew.
It's Opening Day
and the Mets jokes are back.
[ Laughter and applause ]
With a torn labrum, no less.
[ Laughter ]
As you may have noticed,
McCarthy has a lot
in common with Trump,
in at least one
particularly sense --
Trump is both dangerous
and pathetic, at the same time,
which is true of so much
of the GOP, these days.
It's honestly bewildering.
Trump's like one of those cats
that gets stuck on a Roomba,
[ Laughter ]
but then, if you go near it,
he'll hiss
and claw your eyes out.
I mean, look at him.
[ Laughter ]
He looks like he should be
under a car
while an animal control officer
tries to lure him out.
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Yeah, no, in the winter,
like to cuddle up
under the engine for warmth.
Come on out, you varmint!"
[ Laughter ]
You know, we do need
whatever animal control
for former presidents is
right now
because no one seems
to be doing anything
about the fact
that a former president
who incited a violent mob
to attack the Capitol
is still actively engaged
in a slow-moving coup,
intent on dismantling democracy.
It feels crazy.
He's just out there,
shanking drives
and haunting weddings.
[ Laughter ]
It's like if,
instead of a shack in the woods,
the Unabomber had a residency
at Caesar's Palace.
[ Laughter ]
And he's still walking around,
repeating the lie
that the election was stolen.
And that's where
dangerous meets pathetic.
For example,
in a recent interview,
Trump challenged any Democrat
to debate him
on his election bull[bleep].
-Remember I offered
to debate anybody
-Yeah.
-on the election?
You know,
I didn't have one person --
-No one took you up, huh?
-And we'd get big, big ratings.
-Yeah.
-I offered to debate
any Democrat politician
on the election of 2020
and they didn't
because they can't defend it.
-Yeah, sure, that's why
they don't want to debate you.
You're like the high school nerd
who said,
"I asked the head cheerleader
to prom,
but she refused to go
because she can't keep up
with my scorching dance moves.
Thank you,
Arthur Murray Dance Studio."
[ Laughter ]
I want to make it clear
I was that kid.
When other kids passed notes
in class that said...
I passed notes that said...
[ Laughter ]
And, by the way,
the answer is absolutely yes
because, if you know anything
about comic books,
you know it's official canon
that Batman devised a plan
for how to incapacitate every
member of the Justice League,
just in case any
of them went rogue.
But then his plans fell
into the hands of Ra's al Ghul,
who hacked Batman's
computer files,
and then Justice League
got super pissed
and they almost kicked him out.
[ Laughter ]
I'm so winded
from that explanation,
I need to use my inhaler.
[ Laughter ]
And that was today's edition
of "A Closer Dork."
♪♪
[ Laughter and applause ]
Where were we?
Ah, yes, the insurrection.
So, Trump says he challenged
Democrats to debate him
and no one took him up on it.
As we said, it's pathetic
and, plus,
no one's going
to debate you again
after watching you
in an actual debate.
Remember that first one
with Biden,
where he couldn't stop
yelling out random nonsense,
like a nursing home grandpa
watching "Card Sharks"
[ Laughter ]
and the moderator,
Chris Wallace,
had to keep yelling "No" at him
like he was a dog
humping a neighbor's leg?
[ Laughter ]
-I'll ask Joe.
-No.
-The individual --
-No! Hey, Mr. President.
-Which was heavily --
-No. Mr. President.
No, no. Go ahead.
No, no, no. Mr. President.
-$3.5 million, Joe.
-Mr. President.
-$3.5 million.
-No, no, no, no.
Mr. President.
-Go ahead.
-No!
-Can I be honest?
It's a very important question.
-Try to be honest.
That'd be a good thing.
-He stood up.
-No.
-He stood up
-The answer
-and he threatened --
-to the question is no.
[ Laughter ]
-If Trump runs again in 2024,
the Commission
on Presidential Debates
is going to have to give him
a shock collar
or, at the very least,
shoot him
with a tranquilizer dart
[ Laughter ]
whenever it's someone else's
turn to speak.
Of course, that would
only slow him down enough
to make his voice normal.
[ Transatlantic accent ]
Folks, we love the debates,
don't we, folks?
They are very entertaining.
I will tell you that.
[ Laughter ]
The House committee
investigating the coup
keeps holding people
in contempt,
but we need more
accountability than that.
Donald Trump incited a violent
mob to overthrow democracy
and now, he's doing it all
over again
by undermining our elections
in advance of 2024.
He shouldn't be golfing
like a free man.
He should be in a courtroom,
asking to get out on bail
and having a judge tell him
-The answer to the
question is no.
[ Laughter ]
-This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
God's Love We Deliver
cooks and brings
over two million meals a year
to men, women, and children
living with HIV/AIDS,
cancer, and other
serious illnesses
and they need your help,
now, more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the Donate button.
Stay safe. Get vaccinated.
We love you.